today we've traveled over 800 miles
south to one of the country's most
prolific knife making regions with Ben
Abbot America is home to some of the
finest blacksmith shops in the world but
the forge I chose combines two of the
things I love the most functionality and
Beauty today we're heading to the clay
Spencer blacksmith shop in brass toown
North Carolina Jesse Jason gentlemen
congratulations you guys are moving
forward in the second round of this
competition which means that one of you
has a potential of going all the way to
the final round of the tournament and
taking home a check for $20,000 and this
shop right here will get up to $10,000
worth of forging equipment and supplies
now typically at this point they' be
asking you to go home for 4 days to
build an iconic weapon from history but
because you're blacksmith I want you to
build an iconic
tool gentlemen we want you to build
this a four time
Pitchfork good luck guys we'll see you
back at our Forge in 4
Bud right now I'm forging down in
between the times and the socket first
because I feel like if I do that and
then cut the tines I could spend more
time on the tines and they won't be in
my
way I'm going to be doing it out of 5160
spring steel that we recycled from a car
I got to make sure this is right I
really want to focus on getting the
lines equal to each other if I have one
time bigger than the other one it's
going to make it awkward and I'll have
to do a lot more forging on it feel
pretty good about my progress I
accomplished a lot I think I feel pretty
confident with all of the things I did
today on day three I got the heat treat
and the quench really good it's looking
okay so far Pitchfork has to be artistic
so I want to do a fractal burning I hope
to represent my home team of the John C
Campbell Folk School fractal burning
it's a little box with a neon power
supply with essentially like metal nails
if done right it looks really cool it's
a slow process you just turn on the
power it does its thing don't touch it
turn it off move it turn it back on I
like the
build or a pitch for us
hoay I've got to get the seam on the
socket right cuz if you don't it can
split open and it could basically come
out of a handle
all right it's the end of the day I got
my goal reached yesterday I
quenched so I'm really excited about
that yeah to start looking at it then I
put some bluing on the
Pitchfork and it makes a little look a
little different a little
better that set it off I think it looks
really cool now everything's looking
great so time to move on to the handle
okay here we go so this thing has a such
a good fit is really hard to get
in basically forcing and forcing and
forcing and it ain't going are you
kidding me all I can do is just Ram her
home just hope it don't break because if
it breaks man I'm going to be in a world
of trouble and there's no way I can
start over at this
point it's
there I got my handle together I'm
basically done so now I got to test this
thing out enemy watermelon spotted here
we go oh that took his head
off yeah I'm really excited to go back
to the poris and fire Forge feel pretty
confident that whatever they tested on
it will
survive all right blad spiss welcome to
the strength and functionality part of
this
competition I'm going to start by taking
your pitchforks and checking the
functionality of them by doing what they
do putting some hay into a barrel
afterwards I'm going to test the angry
villager side of these things by
attacking the Sandman and then lastly
I'm going to test their strength by
bashing them into the side of this
wheelbarrow Jesse you're up first you
ready yes
sir
[Music]
oh no I knew
it all right Jesse man up until that
last hit things were going great the
grain looks great there nice and tight
grain in there so that wasn't any
problem but I'm guessing on some of the
strikes in the wheelbarrow just that one
interface where the socket goes from
being round to being flat and it has a
little bit of a an elbow underneath
there I think that that was enough of a
stress riser to cause this fracture well
thank you
sir Jesse you survived every one of the
strikes except for the last one but and
unfortunately because your Pitchfork did
break it's considered a catastrophic
failure therefore we cannot continue
testing it but you're not out of this
fight yet Jason in order to move forward
into the final leg of the tournament you
are going to have to survive all nine
strikes are you
ready I am now all right Ben take it
away so watching Ben take that Pitchfork
I'm sweating it there was a spot just
past the socket I kind of ground it thin
right there and that might Poss possibly
break right there especially seeing
Jess's break in the same spot so kind of
[Music]
worried
well Jesse unfortunately for you that
means your time in this competition is
ended you will not be joining us in the
final round we want to say thank you for
coming out fighting so hard but at this
point in time I'm going to have to ask
you to please step off the forge floor
thank you for letting me be
here my pitch workor broke I didn't
expect it to break the way it did but
stuff happens and I'm happy to be here I
learned a lot but also it was an
extremely fun time and I'm rooting for
Mr Jason in the final round because he
has done such amazing work I think he's
got a great
position Jason congratulations that
means you are one step closer to a
$20,000 check to go into your pocket and
$10,000 in Gears and supplies to go to
bells in the John C Campbell Folk School
but you got a long road ahead of you cuz
you got to get through three other
Smiths that we picked up across America
before we send you out I want to ask you
to come up here Shake our hands and wish
you good
luck I'm excited and I think I've said
before I'm not a pitch Fort Smith but I
guess I am now because I've made one and
it passed I'm excited to be the one
moving forward to represent Ben and John
C Campbell hopefully I'll do them well
and hopefully I'll win and we'll all go
home home
[Music]
Happy